let's start off with this uh this larry
elder thing i gotta be honest you know i
think there's so many extremely
important stories right now we've got
obviously the afghanistan stuff which
has been going on for a long time
especially with your your expertise sean
we could we could talk about this but
then as we're coming in and sitting down
i just i saw this story and for one i'm
like this one makes me really really mad
for a few reasons from timcast.com
breaking larry elder attacked by white
liberal in gorilla mask throwing eggs
now personally i don't know if liberal
is the right word to use
it is kind of kind of like the
colloquial word used for like the
opponents but this person's a nut you
know what i mean like i'm not gonna
i guess until the the mainstream
liberals come out and condemn this
actively i don't know what else to say
other than they're in the same under the
same umbrella but the story is
california gubernatorial candidate larry
elder was attacked by a white liberal in
a black and pink gorilla mask in venice
on wednesday the mask wearing leftist
was throwing eggs and shouting as elder
walked by the belligerent attacker also
punched a member of elder's entourage
who was attempting to get them to calm
down and step away one of her friends
also punched him in the back of his head
as someone else threw an egg quote put
your hands on me again and i'll f you up
the ape masked attacker was heard
shouting another protester ranted to the
media present media present that elder
who is black doesn't even like his own
people
quote a flying egg narrowly missed the
back of recall candidate larry elder's
head after was thrown by an activist
wearing a gorilla mask in venice a
scuffle broke out and the candidate was
escorted into an suv kate cagle the
journalist who filmed the incident wrote
in a tweet and i'll tell you what really
bothers me about this aside from the
fact these people are lunatics
is that
if this was someone on the right wearing
a gorilla mask and going up to a black
democrat it would have been it would be
the front page number one above the fold
new york times white supremacy that's
exactly where i was going to
thinking this the entire time as you as
you were speaking that yeah if this were
you know a someone on the right it would
be national news you'd have the today
show out there interviewing interviewing
people oh he was wearing a red hat you
know i mean you know that that would be
the dominant headline oh but i mean i
mean no but this is a gorilla and you
approached this
really really fair right like well this
guy is he's defined as as a liberal but
he's probably just somebody that that's
struggling or oh i i didn't see the news
but right yeah but um
but yeah it's just someone that's a
little crazy you know that not really a
liberal but but if it were a
conservative you would get no such grace
this is this is from anybody this is
what they're saying right so the l.a
times called larry elder the black face
of white supremacy yeah it's insane
which is insane and then a a leftist
wearing a gorilla mask throws eggs and
punches someone in his group
where's all of the headlines where's don
lemon saying ladies and gentlemen white
supremacy is alive in this country a
white man a white woman in a gorilla
mask attacking a black you don't see it
because it's not about race not about
racism all this critical theory stuff is
just we want power
and the double standards fairly obvious
isn't it well
isn't this the
you just look at this and you're like we
need to break up
we need to break up we just go right to
it we need to bring someone through an
egg and we're done
think about what did you just say you
just said that
the press
controls the narrative
until the right gets a way to control
the narrative
they're always going to be in charge i
mean they've spent the last century
taking over academia and the press
i mean
of course you're you're you're so you're
so right and i think for years what the
dynamic was at least for the last 15 or
20 years
the left would set their talking points
and what's interesting about the modern
day left or the the new democrat party
is their talking points are set by three
or four people at the top of their party
and they trickle down to the rest of the
party which is why a congressman in in
western pennsylvania espouses the same
views as a congresswoman in southern
california as in southern florida
they're all the same um so they they set
these talking points and then they in
the past they'd use the media to amplify
these talking points but over time as as
the market changed and stuff you had fox
news created and talk radio and
conservatives had their alternative
media but what what i think is so
dangerous today
is so you've the same dynamic between
democrats setting their talking points
and the media helping to elevate them
but now you have big tech who is
censoring any conservative counterpoint
and i think one of the greatest
threats that we face as a country today
is the collusion between
uh the the modern day democrat party big
tech big business and and big media and
to to sort of take people's freedom away
from them and so you were talking about
like
some sort of alternative alternative
media hopefully over time will get there
but
as long as big tech can shut your
showdown i mean look look at this stuff
they could shut your showdown tonight if
they wanted to well i i will say a lot
of people
have taken for granted the what the
internet has given them or i shouldn't
say it that way that's the wrong way to
put it you can't go on tucker carlson's
show and say
a lot you can't there's a lot of stuff
you can't say on fox news that's true
actually we actually have way more
leeway here on youtube but there's also
things that they can say that we can't
because youtube has editorial guidelines
which are not about community standards
so that is a very serious problem but
i'll tell you you know one of the
biggest problems is
and you can see how the left reacted to
this especially in how they threw eggs
at larry elder
the right never fought back the the
american rights seemed to think that
appointing judges solved the problem and
it didn't the cultural institutions are
where everything comes from and flows
from and big tech is involved in that
and i think a really good example of the
problem
the new york times
can just take any story
say it and every conservative
immediately pivots to address whatever
the new york times told them to talk
about
so there can be some big news like right
now larry elder gets attacked this white
liberal she's a racist white supremacist
i'll say
absolutely how dare she do that and
you're not going to see in the media joe
rogan right we'll get to this in a
minute in greater detail but joe rogan
talks on his instagram channel about
what his doctors prescribe him and cnn
says he's taking livestock medicine
even though people don't trust the media
independent
i mean the media has very little trust
across the board
even with that
still they set the conversation and
something i'll tell you what's
interesting the ukraine gate stuff with
joe biden
when that stuff was going down and i was
researching what was going on with
barisma the corruption of the biden
family i found a lot of uh damning
information but i had to go to eastern
european sources and vet them and it was
very difficult because i'm like i don't
know who these people are right i don't
know if these are credible sources i
don't know why i should trust cnn for
that instance in that in that
circumstance but the interesting thing
was
this is considered fringe because cnn
didn't mention it if cnn doesn't talk
about it and you do it's irrelevant
fringe conspiracy crackpot nonsense
regardless of whether or not cnn or the
new york times or any of these outlets
is talking about something true or false
if you talk about anything off the path
of their controlled narrative and
opposition or or support then you're in
fringe territory that's something that
needs to change the right need to figure
out how to actually set the tone and set
the conversation well you have to also
ask
is the press doing
politicians bidding or are politicians
doing the press's bidding i've i have a
friend who was a reporter and he said he
stood he was in rooms where he watched
reporters bully politicians into
positions oh yeah so look at fouchy and
the mask thing look at the last four
look at the last five years i mean from
two from 2016 to 2018
the republicans had
the executive the judiciary and the
legislative they couldn't get anything
done and then right-wingers were like oh
well that's because the left i'm like
yeah that's because you guys had
you guys thought you had power but the
left was still in power yep and until
people start realizing that and start
looking for alternatives
look at look at this look at russia
the the the mainstream media comes out
and says oh russia russia russia because
hillary clinton said so said so and the
republicans in 2016 and 2018 were like
well you know we should reasonably look
at this and then ukraine gate happens
and it's nothing
this is the problem the republicans you
know what i think it was i think that we
had a uniparty for a long time
republicans and democrats basically the
same thing so the republicans were like
rolling their eyes we don't care about
trump we don't want any of this
but the populist right gaining more and
more power
and they're forced to reckon with it so
i think uh next year 2022 we might see
something really really fascinating that
that being said we might see something
crazy if larry elder becomes governor of
california yeah yes and by the way there
are so many angles to talk about this uh
this very problem from but what you were
talking about about joe biden and and
verism in ukraine and the whole like you
know i said you know fire the prosecutor
who is investigating
my son or my family for corruption or
you don't get the billion dollars right
that is a clear-cut
quid pro quo we'll have to break that
one down though
sure but i'm just saying from 30 000
feet right
you've got joe biden having a
conversation with the president of
afghanistan six weeks before the the
withdrawal four weeks before
the the the collapse of kabul the
conversation went hey you know uh
talking to the president of afghanistan
paint an overly rosy picture of what's
happening on the battlefield essentially
lie to the world to make it seem like
the taliban is isn't as strong as they
are or you don't get the military
assistance it's essentially the same
thing except for
the media just flies cover for them
i can make it very very simple
i love asking this question and uh i'm
gonna ask it now of all of you
do you think that if uh dave rubin after
he got suspended on twitter that twitter
was scared he would show up to twitter
hq with a mob of classical liberals with
pitchforks and torches and bricks start
violently attacking people do you think
jack dorsey was like guys we suspended
dave rubin it's gonna get violent here
we have to we have to unban him you
shouldn't have done this
no absolutely not do you think jack
dorsey had that conversation when they
talked about banning antifa
yes
when they say okay we've got these
people advocating for violence on our
platform what do we do if we start
banning them they're going to come after
us they're going to show up at the
headquarters they're going to smash
things the cops will be powerless
so here's what happens
when when when you have these people
showing up throwing eggs at larry elder
you have uh
these politicians getting attacked when
when the right holds a rally in in the
pacific northwest antifa shows up and
starts attacking people and shooting at
them and now i'll tell you this it's
definitely escalated the point where i
would consider a lot of it to be mutual
combat in the pacific northwest but if
people say i'm gonna have a free speech
rally it's permanent leave us alone and
you show up you started the fight
the right doesn't have any kind of
threat factor they shouldn't the left
shouldn't either but so long as cops are
unwilling to do anything about it
people are going to continually fear
what the left does we were talking about
this the other day
that you know why is it these
institutions like the new york times or
whatever ultimately become woke well
it's because the regular people there
are too scared to say anything because
the the leftists are just terrifying and
fringe lunatics and there's very few of
them but everyone's scared of them and
that's it so long as people are scared
and unwilling so so my respect to larry
elder calmly walking and saying and
ignoring them well can i posit a theory
on that sure
i think the left likes chaos and the
right even if they can't
even if they don't know how to say it
they like order i mean look at right
wing cities
small towns they're
you're not having an antifa problem look
where the left
governs
it's a mess
it's always a mess and
why does the left like disorder like
that because the more disorder there is
the more power that they can take to
themselves and say hey we're doing this
even if they're not doing that and they
may even
want
that disorder maybe that's what happened
last year they knew that they could grow
their power if they let all of this
insanity run through look i want i want
to
i'll say this i'll say this about about
what you were saying
it's
it's not like this is some crazy theory
right like the left has if you would
have told me that the modern-day
democrat party uh four years ago would
be advocating for a position of
defunding the police wholesale right and
and just just anti-police rhetoric they
walked that one back quick they they did
but it has consequences and you're
seeing as you as you mentioned like
crime in almost every major american
city philadelphia in my case in
pennsylvania they also told the police
to stand down so they could have never
chaos i i i agree with you i agree with
you i'm just saying that they're
anti-cop rhetoric coupled with defund
the police coupled with mixed signals
from leadership
creates chaos in in their cities right
primarily democrat power centers and you
see that and you see that empirically as
well with rise and murder rise in crimes
things like that thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you